Dumb. And then one video, Carlos Photo
photo folder, I think his name was,
he was fighting someone in Seattle,
in front of cops,
like some guy agreed to fight him.
And then you see right away
what a terrible idea it is.
Many leg kicks the guy and the guy's got
this look on his face like, oh my God,
you actually know how to fight. He beats
the shit out of this guy. Phoenix Jones.
Yeah, that's what he's called
himself. Phoenix. Look how he dressed,
but watch this video of it. He can see it
on that one too. This is exactly, yeah,
yeah, yeah. So the guys like folk,
you'll fucking kick your ass and
this is in front of the cops.
It's like fuck you. And he's like, you
know, you think you're gonna fuck get,
and he's wearing the superhero costume
on. And he's like, give me some vital.
He's telling the backup, you guys
walking towards the university way.
You're 47 cause wearing an orange liqueur.
Come see you see him wearing
that outfit. Yes. And you think,
oh I can kick this guy's ass for sure.
This guy's a clown. Fucking cosplay.
Dork. Yeah, a little bit, but watch
that. Skip ahead. It's like, okay.
Yeah.
So the guy wouldn't stop badgering him
and then finally in front of the cops,
they agreed to let these dudes Duke it
out. Holy Shit. That's it right there.
Let it go there. Watch this. Oh, that's
when you know you made a mistake.
The first leg moving around,
and again,
you got a useless,
and he's turning to kick too.
He jabbed him to the body. Yeah.
You fucked up. Wow. Yeah. God,
this guy's life style.
That third leg done that
third leg gigs a real problem.
Okay.
Oh, the fourth leg kick. Yeah. Yup.
Oh,
that guy is basically hopping around
on one leg. Oh No. Now it's a beating.
That's it. That's a
wrap. Yup. That's right.
He's combat. You're right. Yeah.
It's a mutual combat law and cops are
standing by watching this guy gate
brained. Yeah. That's
what's crazy is like,
it's very irresponsible for
the cops because that's not
a good fighting surface.
Yeah. Yeah. You can get out. I usually
have a padded area they set aside.